Note that with our setup, this call to an entity's update function, will allow
each entity's unique logic function to be called. For example, the landmine
update function will check against a timer, each frame, to determine whether or
not it should blow up. While self-destructive in nature, this type of
functionality is the backbone of our gaming system.
[SOUND]
Now the game engine is capable of updating all live entities, but it's calling
a blank update method on each entity class instance. We need to fill in each
entity's update method. But this might be a little too involved for a quiz.
Let's instead, look at a single sub class of entity. The landmine disk class
represents a landmine that's been placed in the environment, waiting for an
unknowing robot to walk on top of it. We have a couple properties that make
this possible. First off, is the landmine disk actually defines a lifetime of
100 units. Secondly, is we override the kill function for the entity. To remove
the physics engine body as well as the entity itself once this landmine is
dead. Your job, if you choose to accept it, is to fill in the rest of this
update function where we subtract 0.5 from the lifetime each update call, and
then once we reach the bottom we call the kill function and return out.